cenizas y lodo hasta en los lugares más
recónditos en la isla dejaba el volcán
semeru sigue emanando gases y nubes unas
horas después de su erupción una docena
de pueblos fueron casi enterrados por
completo sorprendidos los habitantes
tuvieron que huir de la caída de gas y
polvo volcánico
todos estaban asustados y con ganas de
huir porque la explosión fue mucho más
fuerte que el año pasado
la seguridad civil de indonesia intenta
localizar a los sobrevivientes atrapados
entre cenizas volcánicas ya ha
encontrado más de 10 cuerpos sin vida y
creen que hay más los rescatistas
avanzan con cautela sobre el terreno de
difícil acceso por la lluvia de las
últimas horas
me pegue a post con un show la
publicación de un look saur informó
sobre la observación de cenizas
volcánicas que caen del cielo hacia vez
se equivocan es en esta área donde el
olor a azufre está más presente por
aroma blair a los animales domésticos
también son evacuados bajo la mirada de
estos monos confundidos por un entorno
totalmente gris las autoridades han
anunciado el envío de ayuda alimentaria
a la región también han prohibido a los
ciudadanos acercarse a menos de cinco
kilómetros del cem eeuu desde su última
erupción hace un año el nivel de alerta
del volcán catalogada de muy alta no ha
bajado